welcome back to gravity falls V logs and
we're back from outer space gonna watch
some gravity falls to see that whole
look on your face it's pretty funny is
that the look yeah hey it's so good the
soda game feels like coming home
especially after seeing 50 shades of
grey it's like oh thank you the actual
good dark still their words and yet had
someone there was coming there was
coming and Helen but not the same time
um this is a kids show okay so this is
the northwest of mansion mystery the low
codes at the end is next up on the used
to be about History Channel did aliens
write the Constitution crawdads and
Tiaras and Florida the show it's true
cuz it's Florida hey boys our next
convention in Florida oh um haha and
then here's the earth it the the one
other code the number code at the end
just repeats three times stand is now
what he seems stand is now what he seems
stands now what he seems interesting
Stan was not in this episode well that's
what's so interesting is realizing that
but there's a big warning at the end
like in 21 hours like the apocalypse is
happening and the funny thing you know
the apocalypse has always happened I
know I know but there's like a counter
in a countdown and stubby see bill
cipher watching again and uh what I'm
what's funny too is that this was a long
time before this episode came out
there's a long gap if I'm right I think
there's another long gap I'm not sure
but the even if there's not I heard
there is in eat a there's even if
there's not this episode oh really good
I really like this at this zone this
episode was great yeah I get it
you opened up just great with that whole
line about um you are my possessions Oh
baby I don't want to try that on my
computer whatever it's at you know at
the end they're like well this is a
really long gap that people have in
between I thought something important at
the end like something back to the
mystery and it was like this great bacon
oh my gosh you can tell us the last mix
oh my god
oh no I wanted this man dipper when he
says like yeah can't we like save it for
tomorrow my dog let's talk about it now
uh so this is an episode it's a Pacific
Northwest episode that's I'm usually not
a fan of those episodes cuz it's like
again you're the bully you're the jerk
uh but it was a really good one because
they do what I think they should do with
bullies is a they make them funny and be
them interesting yes and sympathetic uh
then I'll tell you you want tight
writing that whole bit with the Bell you
don't need to know head everything you
needed you know one thing about
Pacifica's childhood yeah and I'm like
oh my god like the creepiest thing we
could yeah we could look at each other
I'm just like pretty creepy yeah like
I'm I even like oh so gently whistles
Derby I laugh a little bit cuz it's like
a kid show it's over the top but I'm
like no that's like the way she got that
carrot look on her face look didn't mean
me I'm like yeah and you don't see her
genuinely like afraid yeah I'll pay you
to save me or said but it's like she was
like no no I'll be quiet like I will
respect the Bell and it's like whoa
along yeah that and you have no idea
what they did I mean I was to say that
that pretty much gave you all the
sympathy you needed for Pacifica in
seconds Nia seconds I'm like wow that
that just explained everything I know I
didn't even need to know anything it you
know and so many people are always like
what do you have against with chow ski
speeches and Chris rhinoland speech and
what do you anti philosophy anti speed
those peaches are fine when they're
needed but they're not always needed
sometimes just the simplest thing can
get it and man you're righteous every
time the Bell came out you just went
quiet us like God was that uncomfortable
it's like legitimately a cop purple
ahead Morpheus just rung a bell Arnie oh
I think we could have saved a lot of
time and this is just movies yeah uh
know if someone would bring a bell every
time they do a long-winded speech that'd
be great
that Bell would never stop right have
you ever thought about what means
becoming but the philosophy but our goal
is again break the bell uh but we're not
talking about that we're talking about
such anger however that we are talking
about gravity falls uh a ghost is
haunting the man chicas are gonna do
this great big party and only those two
lumberjack lechuck we both thought of
Monkey Island
yeah the flaming beard and it's high in
this place because they keep out the
riffraff they only let the creme de la
creme richest people come in so dipper
and Mabel are coming well specifically
dipper I guess to solve it him and
Pacifica go on this wild goose chase uh
Mabel and her girlfriends try to hint on
a hit on this uh fancy prince
Australia's a baby yeah screening yeah
but the Dumb and Dumber Jo pretty much
uh but it was like cuz it's like you
know so de kangaroos or how's it work I
would like to sing a sweater dress that
her dress was very funny but I thought
what the fight oh they're amazing whiter
sweater watch or as I like to call it
swatch today's sweater was brought to
you by a moose and some pine trees is
yes and other exposure um but is so they
go through and they they're running away
from this ghost the ghost finally says
the only way I'll the curse we broke is
if you let the common folk Ian and
Pacifica finally tells that despite the
riveting deep I'm the ring a date this
was fell down from working we're gonna
eat the fuck yeah we've got enough
sandwiches in the panic room to last a
week we're gonna eat the Buffalo and
everyone comes in just trashes the place
the parents are totally angry and upset
don't learn anything which I like yes
not all told on it well they're gonna
learn something yeah I really like she
defines them and she's not really
rewarded from the parents the parents on
why they're still gonna be me and she's
got pride face some sort of punishment
but it was still the right thing so I
really like that I I am well I think
we've got our post 1d rebound I'm I'm
thinking they're gonna go with poppy on
the feels yeah Ike Ike then feeling some
feel I would not have predicted man what
is
like I could say that I can totally see
that at your count working especially
cuz he did you know it is not like she's
more sympathetic yeah and they are they
start with that
you know like halfway through I think
the Gulf episodes when they tried to
work in that she can be kind of
sympathetic which I never did with
Robbie you know he was always a jerk you
know but here they work in and they give
her this really fascinating backstory
without giving too much detail I mean
like I said just the Bell is enough and
you achieve really feels remorse and
stuff so uh and you see dipper sort of
see that transition as well and it comes
from a place where it's like anyone
would hate her it's not a matter of oh
they're just doing this so they can do a
romance it's like no she was a genuinely
unlikable person and then they gave her
more it was not more it was a great way
to reintroduce her as a potential love
interest as a character you could follow
now and that just be like bitch those
are bonds stereo it what it Mabel say I
don't remember
and she had some line in the Gulf
episode you blonde stereotype oh you
blonde one dimensional statement one
one-dimensional stereotype yeah um yeah
and they yeah I like that because it's
not like oh and they're just gonna hate
each other until they like each other
there's a real genuine understanding
from both sides and it didn't feel for
us it felt very natural um and I guess
it from me and oh and then at the end
yeah mcgucket comes in says the
apocalypse is upon us
yeah laptop and everything and there's a
picture of bill cipher not only watching
but like people burning by a tree at the
bottom so did a nice little oh my god
what's gonna happen uh and the only the
only thing I grunkle Stan and uh
I miss a little bit of Mabel I was not a
very Mabel heavy episode and it was good
despite that despite Thea I mean the the
stuff of the girlfriends was okay I
liked them doing the chocolate cheese
chocolate oh my god then I laughed so
hard a deck is like no you've entered a
sweet savory loop that you can't get out
that's my breakfast feels like good bite
the sweet savory loop every day come on
routine gone too
no no not fondue it's do I want pancakes
or do I want like a skillet or something
pancakes gillip in it and then he get
like pancakes and then you get like
sausage or bacon or something
and then like you get the maple syrup
it's like do I dip the bacon in the
maple syrup do I get chocolate chip
pancakes do I like it's the sweet savory
loop it's just like and when you've had
enough of sweet then you stop looking at
me like I'm crazy
what's your look at you like you're
crazy I'm looking at you like this is
quite the first world problem but I
didn't say it was a real problem I'm
just saying
once you get sick a sweet then you want
savory but then when you do the savory
than you want sweet again it's this loot
no now they still talk about now I'm
looking at you like you're crazy cuz
that's pretty insane to talk you've
never had this problem then I'm very
proud to say I have not like badge of
honor from then you have a boring sad
breakfast it is said you should feel sad
I enjoy my grape-nuts er is the most
exciting of the cereals you right next
to shredded wheat dry is not the
prostate crap I always turn them over
when I saw the fried lactose-intolerant
I only pour water ahh
what is it acceptable in the movie for a
special treat which juice on top ah
that's just nasty uh but no with this
episode the things always stood out to
me outside the stuff we've mentioned
which is all wonderful people dead
reference with the talking animal heads
maybe I kept wanting them we go haha
something you know a lot of really like
if I was a little kid this would be the
scariest episode I would have see how
this episode was pretty quiet there's
like blood dripping from the animals
mouths they all start talking a skeleton
comes out with an access and you see the
axe go into his head he turns them all
into what including all the main
characters like to me it's a little kid
that would be the boy right be like game
over man game oh yeah well you guys are
dipper I'd be right now
oh ya know and they're like Oh their
eyes go like so listening
yeah I mean it's a allows a little kid
even like even now I don't know why but
whatever somebody's turned to like stone
or a statue or can't move I'm like a
robot or something like that even though
I know I can't happen that like really
scares the shit out of me put some
reason I don't know why I never fallen
victim to the sweet-savory loop what do
those two things have in common fucking
nothing I'm just saying you're not
normal so on top of really liking that
it was pretty scary never quite do far
but pretty damn scary for little kids um
I really love the artwork in this one
like it's looks really better and better
soon yeah like the the colors and the
the line work and the motion and the
lighting and the shadows I like when the
Austrian kid came in the background
yeah like the Sun just go behind the
cloudy skies like that Napolean picture
where he's like riding back up on the
horse and it's like it had this epic
quality to it then they bring him like
the music with all these owns like the
food you know I hope the little fishes
disease he'll that just made it a fun
way that just make it a little better
than that not just the voice acting
which is really good this one but the
only dippers voice anymore I realized
that when he started talking I'm like
okay well I four months watching this I
guess that's a cutoff point cuz it
doesn't bother me anymore but I think
you know also like at the very end when
they realize they're on the carpet and
you know she grabs something I throws on
the ground and it's like I'm sure the
script says dipper knocks over plate of
beers or something like that but the way
the enemy it's just like oh oh like that
and then he laughs it's like nah wait
does that make it a little funnier bits
like those little touches where it goes
on its own it probably won't be anything
that's special but after all those other
laughs it just creates that environment
creates that role of laughter we just
enjoy laughing and they just keep
playing those little touches and yeah I
just sort of saw all of them this
episode like you know just the little
touches the great animation the great
voice work great characters you know and
a good story and it didn't necessarily
tie back into the main big mystery which
is why I'm so shocked that I'm like wow
this one was so good because it still
did tie into like what the really big
question
proved you can do a really good episode
without Mabel you don't need me but it
helps don't man that Mabel likes a mabel
horseshoes or grunkle Stan yeah that's
true like a lot of the really big heavy
hitters were not in this one there's
still a little bit of Mabel she was
damaged so she's Emery um but yeah
definitely not a lot of the usual made
big players uh and it was finally he
said it was fine just rode the emotion
of it as well as the comedy and I'm not
usually like a huge fan of like sort of
warmer colors like the Browns and the
oranges and stuff but yeah they Jay did
it really oh it's episode rule in this
um we without revealing what it is the
next NC we reviewed reviewing uh tries
to do this and it just comes across as
very flat and very boring not awful I
mean but it's just not they try to do
some very similar with the shadows and
sort of the colors and stuff and a
trying it could I think we disagreed a
bit I thought it could have been worse
but no it definitely like poison I
didn't mind it as much as you but but
it's like Mantha this did it better yeah
I think because I have such a love for a
you do - we have such a love and a very
gothic um design and architecture and
colors and stuff like that when it's
done well uh it's to be so appreciated
could you see so many people that I'm
sure try very hard and there is artistic
style to it but it's so hard not to fall
into what a million other people have
done already it's so the speaking of
color like I forgot to bring this up in
the last V log we did but on the sweater
watch
I think of armor it was like a rainbow
colored sweater or something but is it
like some sort of LGBTQ thing cuz like
it had that specific look to it I
thought was more like the more you know
star maybe I'd have to I'd have to think
as I remember thinking about it and I
never brought it up well maybe somebody
maybe somebody has an answer no no I I
think that's because you know rainbow
valley is a triangle rainbow I think
isn't that the sign I think why or early
even though I know I I it's been so long
but remember we need to do more research
on I remember thinking it when I look
you had seen it already I this is the
first time we've seen an episode
together that you hadn't already watched
so it's driving me nuts I just remember
thinking that and I didn't bring it up
this is back around Christmas we're
talking about so many other things and I
didn't yeah I didn't bring it up but I
remember thinking I was like I wonder if
that's some sort of LGBT reference like
I but I don't have an answer for that I
was just curious I guess the commenters
I'm sure will say yeah but my guess
would be no because I think it's usually
the triangle like that rainbows rainbow
whatever I know it's like the the symbol
and stuff but it's like the official
symbol I think it is a triangle with the
rainbow ends for some reason remember
thinking wow that really looks like the
flag or something for the but maybe it's
hiding something it's like yes here's
what I'm implying that it's something
not even gay right right yeah I don't
know I just did something I noticed and
I was like oh that seems very specific
and I forgot to bring it up like so and
I just kept remembering like every week
is like when we do this is gonna I was
like bring that up and get it but if you
saw it how to mention it last nope let's
see if maybe believe has such a young
age is very pro game right baby I don't
care she may be not kidding I mean she's
obsessed with what maybe there's nothing
but you me by good could be a Cara um I
think we know who out of those three two
by one problem she well maybe not as you
see she got the nah she didn't like to I
guess all three I don't know well but
you could still be by though Emily no
you're good
it's all we good we said by exactly
answered that so many possibilities um
so yeah if you saw like something like
yes that was a reference that and let us
know if it's just a rainbow is just a
rainbow
I could be out of my fucking mind but
that is the Mabel effects true I'm gonna
need to get another sweater at some
point yes so I'll wrap yourself in more
Christmas lights will be fun
whoo so um yeah that's about it great
episode really loved him you can't can't
wait another four weeks
I want to know wow this sound good such
a good show so I want it now
Rob Ruka more gravity falls he Kolkata
kaali's drop the gravity falls episode
already so great episode and we'll see
you in the next one take care